To do any kind of analysis on the data,
we need significant amount of data.
So let's read data for each stock for
a period of one year,
that is, the year 2010.
You can do this by changing the stock
and the end date as shown here.
Let's see the data frame contains now.
So this is your data frame which has
stock prices for the symbol SPY,
Google, IBM and gold for a year 2010.
We briefly explained
slicing in the last lesson.
In this lesson we will learn how to
do slicing using the data frame we
just created.
There are basically three ways
we can slice the data frame.
First, row slicing.
As the name suggest,
it will give us the required
rows along with all the columns.
This is useful when you
want to compare moment of
all the stocks over subset of time.
This is how you do it in the code.
We use the function .ix
of the data frame and
just mention the start and
the end date in the square brackets.
Here we extract the moment of all
the stocks in the month of Jan.
Note that the start and the end date
should be in the chronological order.
If you write the 31st
Jan date before 1st Jan,
the date frame will give
you an empty data frame.
Even if you remove the .ix function and
just to print DF
passing the dates in the chronological
order, you will get the same result.
However, .ix is considered to be more
Pythonic and robust, so we follow that.
Now let's run the code to see the stock
prices for the month of January.
You can observe that we get the data
only for the January month but
for all the symbols,
this is known as row slicing.
Second way of slicing is useful when you
want to view prices of only one stock
over the date range,
in this case you can use column slicing.
We want to project the prices of
Google for the entire year of 2010.
Here is how we do it.
A square bracket along with the name of
the column and do not forget the colon.
To retrieve a single column
we just pass a single label.
To select multiple columns
we pass a list of labels.
Let's print this.
And this is the output for
multiple columns.
The last way of slicing is to
slice through both dimensions,
that is rows and columns.
The most robust way to do this is using
the IX selector of the data frame.
Let's go ahead and use it.
If you need more than one column,
you define them in a list like this,
and date range
are separated with a colon.
Here you go, the stock prices for
the symbol SPY and
IBM over the date range
10th March to 15th March.
One application of this way
of slicing is to compare
multiple stocks over a period of time.
Panda support many ways of slicing
a data frame to suit different needs.
Find out more using the link
in the instructor notes.